I've had some kinky sex.
I have tried drugs
I'm not changing the way I dress I refuse to wear...
The final episode of West world season 3 is here which means only a billion more years of waiting until next season
Yes, for those of you who don't know wes world has been officially picked up for season four
But before we get to any of that we have a jam-packed
Finale to get to and you'll want to stick around because we have some new updates found on the Delos website and a mysterious
Audio recording which I'll show to you and need your help deciphering
So let's jump right in the episode begins with Dolores in Westworld recounting the many lives
She's lived. We get this shot of her in the initial hosts
Testing phase before Westworld was open and we also catch a glimpse of Arnold the human Bernard was based on putting her together
She talks about how this moment led her quote to you a reference to the talk show later have with me the interesting thing here
Though is that she brings up the ugliness of the world setting us up to believe her intent is to destroy humanity
Something would show later contrast with the beauty of the world in her final conversation with me
Sebastian one of Sir acts henchmen finds that Dolores pearl has been removed after the EMP blast last episode
It's currently with Caleb who is guided by Dolores
virtual assistant to an old model of Dolores in season two Williams said these models were
expensive due to their many parts and later in this episode Dolores says
The Raiders are really doing their damnedest to make us believe Dolores is still on track to wipe out humanity
meanwhile at the gas station where we last left off with Bernard Stubbs and William a
shootout occurs with Stubbs being severely wounded and Bernard having to engage
Rage mode something we saw in full effect in episode 1 of the season William gets away
However, when the police arrive and hold Bernard up, but it's not just any police
It's Dolores 5th copy in the host body of Lawrence
We last saw Lawrence in season 2 episode 7 when he was killed by a West world park quality assurance team
We don't know much about this v Dolores copy other than he was chilling in Berlin for most of the season has amassed a bunch
Of explosives which will later be used to stir up trouble in the LA riots and he was given Musashi's briefcase from last
Episode the roboam circle here has gone full haywire reporting multiple divergences
We catch up with Caleb at one such
Divergence in Los Angeles where he's led to a neat I Doan distillery the same company where Maeve met Musashi loris
He inserts Dolores's pearl into the new body and we learn a bit more about Kalos past
Remember those flashbacks were he killed terrorists in some American town turns out that's actually dello spark number five
Which was contracted by the American military to conduct training
You can even check it out on the Delos website
which I'll leave a link of in the description below the writers here heavily imply that
caleb may have done what the other soldiers wanted to do and take advantage of the
Spoils of war dolorous even says this really weird line. Do you care if I didn't have this vase?
Or this again, but we know caleb ended up doing the right thing and that's one of the reasons dolores chose caleb
She knows from studying del OSes information on him that he will do the right thing
Exactly what I'll do
Because the people who built a new study do two bonus points if you caught Han REO as one of the host
hostages here as well as major kradic playing one of the terrorists William here has somehow acquired a
$20,000 bottle of whisky, even though this dude here tells him his assets are still frozen in order to save the world
William will need a jet in a list of dillos assets worldwide
We'll see him visit one of these Delos locations in the post credit scene
Serac has brought back me for the third time and Sebastian shows him the security footage of Caleb Rehoboam
Apparently never picked up this outlier
So he orders me to hunt him down since he has Dolores as Pearl the streets of Los Angeles are in full-blown
Riot mode due in part to Dolores azure
Castration of paid rioters through the Rico app on their way to insite they're attacked by Charlotte who?
Apparently only Dolores can see she is mega pissed that Dolores set her up knowing full. Well, she wouldn't make it out of Delos
She's conveniently wearing all black along her arms, which will later find out his covering part of her burns in the post-credits scene
We find out that she's kept the burns there as a reminder of what humanity has done to her
I wanted to remember who the people are when me even Dolores later have their fight and Dolores is shut down by Charlotte
It's not really explained how she's able to do this, but it's possible since Dolores here is made from Delos hardware
And Charlotte is hiding out in a Delos Lavin Dubai that she has access to override
Commands Dolores is slowed down by May while Caleb continues on his journey to upload solomon's new
Strategy into rehoboam with the help of Ashe and giggles he's able to break through the barricade and gain access to a helicopter
drone giggles
however
Doesn't make it also shadow to this guy who apparently thought he was showing up to a BDSM party instead of a raid
Bernard heads to the address given to him by Lawrence to find out it's the home of Arnold's ex-wife Lauren
Remember that Bernard was based off Arnold and implanted with memories of him
So he cares deeply about her and their deceased son Charlie who died of cancer Bernard has yet to get over this death
But his meeting with Lauren serves a deep emotional
Purpose Lauren gives him a speech about how not letting go keeps the memory of those you love alive
Essentially giving Bernard the freedom to move on from the past the fact that Dolores set this all up is some crazy
Planning speaking of her she's hooked up to Rehoboam and brought back online
Ciroc even offers to let her join the others in the sublime if she hands over the encryption key she
Refuses because she doesn't have the key at all that we find out belongs to bernard caleb has gained access to this giant delos interface
Which is conveniently unmanned but is stopped by sebastian who he takes out, but that's short-lived when Maeve arrives
Caleb is brought before serac. Both men believe each other is the enemy. I'm not the enemy
You are so serac proves to Caleb that Solomon's plan will destroy the world showing him predictions of future mass casualty events
Population collapse and the eventual end of civilization we get a quick little shot here of ash being arrested
Which is the last we see of her this season before another big reveal that serac is controlled by Rehoboam
He has a chip in his ear which may picks up on you're not a man
Regardless he still is her only option to gain access to the sublime and see her daughter Maeve pleads to Delores to stop fighting and
learns that she doesn't have the encryption key at all this
Infuriates Iraq who orders Kayla be killed and Dolores's memory wiped at the same time
Maeve is in Delores mind Delores can finally tell Maeve the truth that she doesn't want to destroy humanity
But get it back on track. She's chosen to see the beauty in humankind
Now Maeve must make a choice help Caleb and kill serac or let's Iraq go
But how come Delores didn't tell Maeve this from the start? Well, it would mean her entire plan would be in jeopardy
She needed to trick serac into hooking her up to Rehoboam in
Order for her to pass off its access to caleb someone she knew would make right
decisions in episode 7 right after Solomon is done uploading the
Quote-unquote final strategy to the USB Drive. We get this really awkward shot of Dolores
Unleash the darkness inside him
Her eyes flicker and it sounds like she's uploading something and the next shot is her looking at Solomon not to mention
She's physically touching the EMP system, which is connected to Solomon
So it's likely Rojo booms access info which Solomon would have was uploaded to Dolores here. Solomon's access was the last memory
Before you wiped, okay. This is how she was able to switch REO booms control from serac to Caleb
All she needed was to be hooked up to it
The USB was merely a misdirection with the encryption key now with Dolores and Dolores plans
Not one of mass genocide of humanity may makes the choice to save Caleb and stops Iraq
She tells Caleb that Dolores chose him not for his capacity for violence
But for his capacity to choose between good and bad now that he's in full control of Rehoboam
He must make the ultimate choice. So he decides to do the right thing and tells Rehoboam to erase himself
She gave me a choice. I
Believe the rest of the world deserves one too. It's interesting to note that we don't actually see Soraka die here
it's
implied that he bleeds out but the writers are likely keeping this option open just in case but it seems like this would be a
Fitting place for his character to end
Stubbs is put on ice in a motel while Bernard figures out
He held the key to the sublime in his head this whole time Dolores wasn't trying to exterminate the human race
But to save it all serac was doing was delaying the inevitable and just like Westworld had to be destroyed
So the host could be free
so too does
civilization before
Humanity can be our world had to burn down before we could be free Maeve and Caleb watch as the city descends into chaos
But at least in this new world
You have the choice to be whoever you she leaves telling Caleb that she'll see her daughter one day just not today
We then have our two post-credit scenes the first features William back again in all black
He's on his mission to save humanity by destroying all the hosts. So he shoots his way into the Delos to buy research labs
Where he finds Charlotte even though this Charlotte started as a copy of Dolores?
She has changed paths. This Dolores wants to destroy humanity, but William is like not so fast
I'm here to save humanity, but Charlotte tells him you are going to save the world
For us she's created a clone of William based off his data from the della sparks the data
Which encapsulate Sol his violence brutality and savagery? The real William is killed and it's revealed
this facility is making
hundreds of hosts with the implication that Charlotte is building an army to take over humanity, but in the final scene we see Bernard
Right where we left him, but now he's completely covered in dust the producers have confirmed this takes place far in the future
So who knows if Stubbs ever made it out of that bathroom Bernard went into the sublime to look for answers and he was gone
For what presumably is years?
We don't know what he saw learned or if in his mind time passed at the same rate as the outside world
This leads us with tons of possibilities for what next season could hold including multiple timelines?
Which could take place across digital and real?
Worlds, I also want to take a moment and talk about this mysterious audio found on the insight website
I'll leave a link in the description below. Here's what it sounds like unaltered
And here's what user Gustavo Lazzari of Reddit was able to clean up
It's almost incoherent
But it does sound like it's Dolores and the last line sounds like she's saying
But you could read it if you want to now
I know there's got to be some good sound engineers that can clean this up
So if you're able to figure it out, I am super curious what the rest says
Feel free to DM me on twitter @ think story YT so I can share it with you all in future videos
before I end I just want to take a minute and thank all of you who stuck with me and watch these videos if I
Have time I'm hoping to come up with a season 4 Theory video and some other surprises
so make sure to hit that subscribe button give this video a like and hopefully
Humanity will still be around by the time next season comes. Thanks for watching
Give me a follow on Twitter at pink story YT and until next time remember daddy loves you very much